so how did you say how does a man
identify a good woman
I would say that a man identifies a good
woman if she's one healthy and fit
that's important okay especially for
childbearing and I'd say number two if
she has Traditional Values if she
believes in being submissive if she
believes in being feminine she she she
loves I'm going to answer that question
we're gonna get to the men okay don't
worry
sitting you know and then I think if she
wants to cook if she's okay cleaning she
wants she's a homemaker she would love
to you know have children and take care
of them and be a housewife I think
that's beautiful and so that's what I
think identifies a good woman okay
um what about you well identifying as a
good woman nowadays is a bit difficult
however I would emphasize on the values
and uh the morals of the woman
um primarily her ability to be a good
wife her ability to raise good children
and even her thoughts and the things she
has in mind because she's going to be
molding the Next Generation and uh so
how does he know well it can because you
know women lie like we can just say
things like I'm
but you know if you have a deep
conversation with a person
but believe me throughout time you can
identify okay so how much how much time
if it's um I would say I would give it
like three months but it can okay so
three months of constant um
constant uh meeting
okay so you think in three months he can
see if she has traditional value yes
okay she would I mean just so healthy so
he can look she healthy and fit cool
yeah
um is she how can he test if she's
submissive
he can ask something and see the
reaction so ask her to do something and
see what she does for example you can
tell I mean if a man tells to a woman
can you uh please make me a coffee or a
meal and she said hell no I'm not doing
this to you I mean that's all right use
it for three months ask her to make him
a coffee
okay
[Laughter]
I'm just writing I'm writing what okay
uh what what else can he do how does he
act uh does he like what else what else
does he do
I mean well uh because I was here just
find a good woman so I'm just trying to
get from the women how do the men just
find a good woman
yeah it's his ability to identify what
he values in in a woman okay I mean
that's gonna be subjective to an extent
yeah so I'm asking like what what makes
someone a good woman and how does he
identify that I think what you were
saying as well men do test women I've
been tested by men like with certain
things so like oh can you cook for me
can you make me food or like on the spot
though asked to it
but it really happens you know it's a
good test it really happens
do you know how to cook can you cook
properly properly even your presentation
that's how you deliver the food I drink
a gravy on the side
step by step for that where I'm gonna
let the men talk I'm just curious how
it's gonna align with what you guys say
or from the women and the men
um okay so first he's got to see her for
three months ask her to make him a
coffee and ask to cook oh I disagree
with all of that I think that honestly
if it's a high value man most of the
time he's gonna know without all of that
honestly most of them nowadays how does
he know
um there is this I don't know if it's
the right word but there is this this
Aura there is this sense when you sit
with a woman who you know is going to be
respectful to you or not I honestly feel
that I think that average men just know
this because you're talking about high
value that's like yeah that's like five
percent I know but but average man
nowadays look at high value men's
content more and more and more okay and
try to see so you think and I think you
think I'm just curious you think men
just know
they don't just know but they should get
to a point
to just know so they they have how so
how does he get to that point that he
just knows well slowly slowly slowly
we're getting to a point where I think
they need to go to certain parts of the
world to know and certain parts of the
world they will just know that 90 of the
women will not be like that and okay so
he has to travel too slowly we're
getting he needs to travel somewhere
else and then experience those women and
then compare exactly exactly okay but
for for a guy that doesn't travel like
he stays in the west because most
remember most guys don't make a ton of
money like I think half of uh us men
don't have passports yeah so so most men
aren't traveling like that so for God
it's not traveling how does he know good
woman versus bad woman I would say if
you if the first conversation with her
is like oh so where are we going to
dinner are we having drinks this is not
a right way to to meet I think when you
meet a girl you should take her for
coffee and that's it even if you like
her so much that you take on a coffee
date and see what she's like and see if
she she's I don't know if she wants to
continue the date and get you to buy her
dinner and can a man know a good woman
from a bad woman without experiencing a
lot of women
no not really okay so so in order to
identify he asked what
uh he I would suggest that in in his 20s
he dates as many women as he can that's
right that's what okay okay so so how
many women should he date
yeah as much as you can yeah
date as many women as possible to tell
the difference I read it because again
remember I just want to remind everybody
the stats one out of three women has an
STD one out of three women has had an
abortion 38 of women are of kids are
born into single parent homes meaning 38
of the Next Generation has never seen a
functioning marriage
um average child first child is before
the average age of first marriage so the
first kid 26 first marriage 30 half of
marriage is will end in divorce average
number of partners for a woman is
between four and eight um and
that's self-reported so you know take
that with a grain of salt but women have
a 20 chance of being in a happy marriage
if they have slept with more than five
people so
um yeah and if men get divorced they can
be financially ruined and their kids can
be taken from them um 70 of women are
overweight so basically there's a lot
riding on them picking the right woman
so I'm trying to give them a foolproof
plan
that makes sense there's a book that I
read called sex a Dawn and in this book
they were making a case basically for a
polyamory and polyamorous relationships
which I don't resonate with personally
but I was trying to convince myself
because everyone else seems to think
that's a good idea except for me so I
thought well I gotta read this book but
at the end of the book they had a very
interesting fact about the olfactory
um sense right your nose like actually
we sniff each other out
a woman can tell if a man will
compliment her differences genetically
I've heard that yeah and then but a
woman actually can't if she's taking
birth control
oh it's disabled but a man can actually
sniff her out he can genetically
identify through his olfactory you know
sense through his nose whether or not
she'll complement his genetic weaknesses
so how does he know like what does he
have to smell for I don't know that's a
good question
but apparently it's like a deep very
primal thing about so maybe attraction
maybe make sure she's not on birth
control yes right for example not on
birth control I think that works both
ways now I wonder what percent hold on I
wanna I just want to look up because I'm
curious what percent of women are on
birth control also who hears on birth
control raise your hand no one not
anymore I mean clearly one out of three
are having abortion somewhat it can't be
that high
uh the majority uh but oh 90 of women
have used contraceptives throughout
their reproductive years
um and have used more than one in their
lifetime 76 percent
wow okay we just have a good room I
guess I'm gonna add that to my stats
okay
um sorry can I just add one more thing
that came to my mind
um ask her about the family you know
sometimes I do understand that not all
of the parents can stay together of
course there are special situations but
just see how she talks about her family
what is her relationship like with her
family and her her Dad too you know so
if a girl even if a girl is not in on
good terms with her dad but she
disrespects him by talking trash to a
guy that's not a girl that you should
marry honestly and if I don't think you
can disagree with this because there's
no even if you haven't got a great
relationship with your or your father's
absent it doesn't mean that the woman is
going to be a wreck it is
why do we have the phrase daddy issues
if it doesn't mean anything but some
most people will not okay a lot of
people that have daddy issues and we
don't know who they are I'm one of them
but I'm not a disrespectful person to
men like I'm not well yeah we're not
talking about you but in general like
it's your dad no matter what like I
think if you've never if you've never
seen a healthy relationship how would
you know how to do it exactly like if
I've never seen anyone ride a bike how
would I learn to ride a bike it's common
sense I feel like it's like morality if
it was common then why do half of
relationships end in divorce and why is
the older generation known for being so
unhappy in their marriages because men
pick women based off the off the surface
they don't actually get uh get to find a
deeper meaning if women swipe right on
dating apps which is the most
superficial only five percent of the
time immense vibrate fifty percent of
the time who's more superficial men or
women women but mostly men are hoes
that's incorrect one out of three men
are either virgins or haven't had sex
around one out of one out of three men
are either virgin or haven't had sex in
the past year wow I think a lot of women
sleep around so yeah a lot of women do
sleep right now
so you're saying we're the same yeah
it's like 20 of men are [__] all the
girls essentially in their 20s and then
when women hit 30 they'll expand it like
basically like women typically go for
looks in their 20s
um women pick like when women this is
the first time in history where women
have been the sexual selectors so like
historically think about it you had to
get along with the dude or you die yeah
like they would pay they would pick you
you wouldn't pick them uh but now this
is the first time where women have been
100 in control of reproduction because
we have birth control we're in control
of abortion so we are 100 in control of
who's born and it's funny because the
more freedom women get the more we screw
the same people in our Prime which is
like 22 to 24 um they surveyed men
between like 20 and 80 and they said
when do you find women most attractive
it's like roughly 22 to 24 all the ages
think that so when women have the most
Choice it's interesting because we pick
non-monogamy
and we and we tend to go for looks and
women react out of emotion yeah solely
out of emotion a lot of the time which
is why you see so many women sleeping
with so many men and making decisions on
the spot that aren't responsible like
abortion yeah so majority of women not
going for men that's not monogamous then
why they fight for man to be monogamous
I mean I think they want him to be but
so they want to change the man basically
they see a man
they're gonna put a top 20 or whatever
which they know is they can tell that he
gets a lot of girls or whatever yeah so
they want to try and lock down that one
man so you don't yeah okay I mean I
think that's like every girl's you know
it has a you know what Cinderella was
sitting at home and the prince like came
and picked her out of all the princesses
exactly they want to say I was the one
who changed him they've been selling us
this dream forever
exactly
um so what do you what do you think of
that does that change your perspective a
little bit
um
not right kinda not really no okay what
does it not change I just don't think
that
um
men are looking for things they don't
have themselves they look they don't
have the minerals for the things that
they want and the women so they just
pick women based off looks they don't
know what they want anyway like they
think they know what they want but they
haven't even got the minerals anyway is
it possible that women don't have what
they want absolutely right absolutely
how would they pick it if the dating
pool has like one out of every three
women's had an abortion one of every
three women has an STD
um like 38 40 grew up without a dad so
they don't have that model like how
would they where how would they know
yeah who good woman is yeah like they've
never like what percent of men have like
even seen a true traditional woman I
don't think yeah do you know any women
with like recipe books
is nice too but only like the upper High
celebrity profile people yeah and then
these two now yeah okay and my whole
family and then when I go there they're
like oh so modern you know everyone
still Cooks the same meals and so
um but so I'm just curious like when
you're hearing these stats like assuming
I'm telling you the truth you don't
think like it puts more of the
promiscuity on women because we're only
sleeping with 20 of men so like that
means 80 of us are sleeping with 20 of
men
hmm
as many
as men talk and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible